a massive and deadly storm system is
causing dangerous flooding from Texas to
the Great Lakes nine people have died in
this storm flood watches and warnings
are in effect for tens of millions of
people this morning DeMarco Morgan is in
Goshen Indiana where the rising water is
forcing some people to evacuate demarco
good morning go good morning to you just
take a look at this parking lot right
here behind me at the shopping center it
is completely covered in water you can't
even make out the floor lanes here along
Lincoln highway of strivers try and make
their way through this street but
officials have been handing out sandbags
to try and stop the flooding but the
National Weather Service says
evacuations are necessary
emergency crews used boats to evacuate
people and pets from this neighborhood
near the rising boggle Creek water has
come up a lot faster than what we kind
of anticipated from the time we've
gotten here I believe the waters come up
probably about ten feet inside some
homes the flood waters were ankle deep
on Indiana roads it's harder to tell
exactly how bad the flooding can be if
you're driving down the road and you see
road closed sign it's gonna be a good
clue that the road is closed and you
should turn around and find a better
route the Indiana State Police is
warning drivers against rolling the dice
on roads covered by flood waters can be
very dangerous you don't know what's
underneath that water the road could be
washed out and it could be extremely
deep and Bangor Michigan the fire chief
gave us similar warning you want
everybody safe you want everybody go
home at night and not get hurt I don't
have to come and rescue or come and tell
you that you've lost another one
the storms dangerous not just limited to
rain and flooding the National Weather
Service says it spawned a two EF siro
tornadoes in Texas one sliced through
these homes in De Soto just south of
Dallas I went in the kitchen and just
when I come out of the kitchen the whole
roof caved in now even as the rain stops
in parts of the Midwest the flooding may
get worse and a snap of cold air is
expected to follow causing winter
weather advisories from Illinois all the
way to Texas
John DeMarco thanks